us and a different, really different from the world. So he has been trying to get to know
this body and stuff and trying to see what he can do with this because his mind is not the same
as he was before. So he's trying to get some of his stuff that he had to work, but to make up with
the things that he doesn't have, he's trying to get his strength back. So he's trying to learn
martial combat from roba and some other stuff from Baptiste and Nautilus.
Well he is severely depressed, but that's not new.
So obviously I'm cooking some food and I guess now teaching Bob some things about some things
with some combat, but also I'm going to say, go ahead, but I'm also going to try to teach those
horses how to respond to those whistles I got in my pack.
First match I knew the dog. So yeah, I'm teaching those horses how to respond to those whistles.
Oh and I'm also playing with that pan that I got just messing with it.
Yep. Yep.
Mostly getting the shape ready to go again, start in a punn supplies and stuff.
Get some, get some shotgun harder to repair the gillic of damage.
And be in the medical for a bit.
Getting Bob fixed up, getting Bob this fixed up.
I like mine.
I want the cheer, but I seem to be good with my stuff. I got a bomb, so yeah, that's good
depression.
They'll need to look at it. I would like to work on mine to like fit the character more.
I've had a busy week so I know it's
(ографmusic)
Bro, I got a spice jar that will let me like conjure an air element.
Yeah, like bro, do you know I could just top that spice on a little something you know, be Roma blazing.
You know what I'm saying?
Exactly.
Oh, another thing is I forgot to mention it earlier because I actually got most of the stuff, but remember the mountain he probably did that in the week time.
(Pause)
I have a teaspoon of social butterfly.
And...
Do you have a social butterfly?
Well...
You got a grandma.
He's been talking with people throughout the week.
So he's been calling Mira in that conversation with Mary.
He's just like asking about the troubles to join us.
Then he's going to talk to Cala to see if he can get his bell fragment.
Then he's going to be helping riff with like the Kingdom's management for the week.
Soaking in the glory of helping get their freedom.
(Pause)
I'm just trying to see if they can combine and what happens when they ring if they're combined.
I don't know like before though when things have happened it's been because of the rings that have helped me. Well not the ring, the fragment.
I would like to try to take off the rings while holding both fragments.
I don't have a good arcana.
Here's your chance. Roll that 20.
You stole the net 20.
(Pause)
Okay.
Did the animals come for the cake yet?
(Pause)
Oh.
So a fairy.
(Pause)
That's a wawa.
Is that a two wawa?
Is she being a wawa?
(Pause)
She got himself a little minishoving.
He got...
He got a fucking saber-to-tiger?
That's dope.
(Pause)
Yeah.
It was dope.
Wasn't it?
(Pause)
>> I'm not sure though.
>> So vacant.
>> Realign--
>> Yeah.
>> All right, and I just want you to--
I think this is going well.
What kind of characters do you play?
>> Bring down your mic if you want
to pick up Friday.
All right, this is usually about
the date.
>> First of all.
>> So have you ever did a number
of moon posts or something?
So inspired.
>> Gonna doπο,roller?
You would do 02.
Take me for a picture next door.
>> It'll go like this,
but I'm sure you're not sure.
>> It is a one.
>> It really does belong to me.
>> Yeah, um, we can--
[ Pause ]
>> Yeah.
So the way villains have their like hat
and they're like stroking
in that time when I had this dog constantly walking
around with it.
>> Yeah, Bob, the thing hates you.
[ Pause ]
>> That's it.
>> What about the same as that?
>> It's taking a year already.
[ Pause ]
>> And this is next here, this world.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
[ Pause ]
>> Animals love me.
>> Oh, I'm fine with just the dog.
Even though I would have preferred a blackstack.
>> Well, I need to go talk to Ben or so.
>> I'm going to be a cook at the end.
>> And I'll jump at once.
[ Laughs ]
[ Pause ]
>> I'm going to be cussing him out.
>> Don't fucking talk to that.
[ Pause ]
>> I'm going to be like, what are you feeding first?
And then I'm going to be like,
okay, well, you better start seasoning the meat.
It's a fucking saber, too, Tyke.
[ Pause ]
He is on our ship, sir.
He will be on our ship.
You're going to give him unseasoned meat.
You're just going to give him raw meat.
[ Pause ]
Yeah, that's why they all left.
That's why they all left.
You better season that up.
Treat him like he's your mother.
[ Pause ]
What the hell do you think you're doing?
You almost sprinkled this.
You got a massage in there.
You just can't just rub it.
You got a massage flavor in it.
[ Pause ]
What the hell?
Massage.
Not be goddamn stuff.
[ Pause ]
There we go.
Yeah.
Now you just sprinkle a little bit.
You rub it in there and get in the groove.
All right.
Oh, it's certainly on thin and a kitchen.
When the roll was selling, it was the meat.
And it was just the...
Now, how you going to prepare this?
You're going to cook it.
You're going to steam it.
Like, what are you going to do?
He's on our ships here.
We don't give anybody just raw stuff.
Every meal is a fine one.
Get him right.
You don't just throw it.
Sir, how are you going to give this to him?
I need to know.
So if you're going to plate it up to him,
you're going to have to see it.
You're going to have to take one of these pans here.
And I'm going to rub it.
I'm going to throw it in my pan.
Get it nice and hot.
And then you're going to take your meat.
You're going to put it on the pan.
Two minutes aside.
Yep.
You're going to see the sides.
And all sides.
Two minutes.
You know when it's done, when you pick it up,
and you still see that juice flowing,
but it's got a nice sear to it.
It's going to be a nice brown to the top.
So, yep.
And then you go...
And then you're going to take it to your plate.
And you're going to do about a quarter of an inch slices.
Nice, nicely really thin.
And it should still be a little pink on the inside.
So you know what's good.
And it's going to have some juice.
And then you're going to garnish it with a little rosemary,
a little thyme.
Make it look nice.
That's how you go to serve it to him every time.
[COUGH]
Oh no.
Who is the SSR?
Oh my god.
Who got the shape?
[LAUGHS]
Obviously I have a minus five.
[COUGH]
I see the meat.
I'm going to be like...
I'm going to be like, what the hell did you do to that?
I gave you specific instructions.
And now you're going to serve that to him.
Oh sweet dear Lord, baby Jesus.
Oh my god, what did you do?
Well we can't let it go the way.
I gave you specific instructions.
Two minutes aside.
That side's burnt.
That is definitely not two minutes.
[COUGH]
You better start practicing.
You taking care of him.
[COUGH]
Well you got to give him that.
We ain't got, we ain't gots.
You think we just got supplies like this?
Yeah, you uh, but watch your ass.
Yes.
Okay, I just want to.
So putting it off there.
Oh shit.
It's almost like your two.
It's just about that.
I don't know.
Is it all right now?
Nice.
Oh nothing, I was just saying let's just hope the sabre two
minutes.
You just be careful.
That's it.
It's fair about to leave soon.
I think I'm just fixing the last things.
Yeah, sir.
Well, he is doing his normal like regular practices and stealth.
He's not usually usually he's usually found in his like room,
but now he is more on the outside.
So I'm trying to practice trauma has been teaching him and so on.
Yeah.
Are you taking one of the horses?
I want the wolf to attack that monkey because that monkey harassed me.
Yeah.
Oh, buddy, it's okay.
I'll go ahead and leave.
I'm moving.
I'm going to get in the dirties look.
I will bite the slap him.
I'm going to get in the dirties.
Thank you.
So do I see finish here?
You know, I'm going to get in the dirties.
I'm going to get in the dirties.
I can't hear exactly what they're saying.
Let's do that.
If you get in the dirties, I'm going to get in the dirties.
I'm going to get in the dirties.
I'll just head in.
I just need it time.
I'm going to get in the dirties.
I want to speak to you about me taking dribbles with us.
As you know, we have many things to accomplish.
We just learned the other day.
Someone that we are connected to.
She's currently being held captive in this set for execution.
Then we also have to go rescue the dribbles who is also captured, drove in,
and then we still have issues to handle.
Regarding the sixfold and other things and all of these.
You do know Linus isn't particularly available, correctly correct.
I understand.
I'm going to get in the dirties.
I did not mention the name.
I feel we should be the ones to do the rescue.
I hope it's solved.
If someone from my crew isn't expecting you to get paid every time they do something.
I hope you're doing well.
Let me correct you on something.
I'm not going to be able to do anything.
I mean going after the sixfold is no easy feat, especially with the relations that they currently have with the crew.
I'm being very persuasive.
I'm not going to be able to do anything.
I'll say good.
Are we in the lower deck of his ship?
No, he's handed it to me right here.
No confidence.
I'm not going to be able to do anything.
Hello, when will people learn not to challenge me?
Who's handed it to me?
Who's touching me?
If you're part of Blackhams crew, you probably have been through a couple of things.
I'll turn to the crew.
How do you feel?
I'm not going to be able to do anything.
What do you mean?
The second game will be a feast of...
Monkey Dog Fight?
I'm not going to be able to do anything.
Why don't we get faked right?
I'm not going to be able to handle the second beat.
Improvision is best.
The second battle shall be the Battle of Beast.
I'll turn to Cade.
What contest should we have the...
Let's do that.
What arena is he talking about?
Is there an arena in the kingdom that we can go to?
I'll ask one of the guards.
We can hold a contest of many feats and have fights.
Let's do that.
Let's go around the kingdom and tell them the people, the savers of the kingdom are going to be putting on a feat of their strength.
I'll look over my shoulders to Pinterest.
We'll see you soon.
Let's go around the kingdom.
We need to get ready for the battle.
Is there something I would know?
I would never use the double fruit.
Bob, if you were so frightened by a double fruit,
The goal is to win.
We need to get ready for the battle.
We have rested enough.
How far is he from me?
The first one was 17, second one is 11.
The pieces have been struck in the both more and more.
Neither did I.
I hope I did end.